and the President of the Russian
Federation Vladimir Putin
until very recently the Arctic has been
seen by many as a room as a remote
corner of a planet mostly untouched by
the great affairs of the world but
that's all changing as global warming
melts pathways of the Arctic it will
become an important thoroughfare of
trade cutting the length of time for
example it takes to travel probably
Atlantic the Pacific by 40% it is also
becoming a new source of energy for the
world we have LNG from the Yamal
Peninsula going east and west to China
and markets in Europe some experts
estimate that the Arctic accounts for
1/5 the world's undiscovered oil and gas
reserves and as the arcade becomes more
important it's also becoming the focus
of increasing military and political
tension peaceful for so long
the Arctic risks now becoming a new
theater for conflict and tension among
the great powers ultimately the Arctic
is now more important probably than at
any point in human in world history my
name is John Farrar a senior executive
editor of Bloomberg News and I'm
delighted to discuss these topics with
our esteemed panel today so in the
beginning we're going to hear some short
speeches from the panelists before
embarking on what I hope will be a
lively and meaningful debate let me
introduce the panel again very quickly
we have Ana's Sola Derek the Prime
Minister of Norway we have Stefan Libyan
the prime minister of Sweden we have
Solomon esto the president of Finland
and we have goodne Hansen the president
of Iceland's and of course the President
of Russia Vladimir Putin who will now
give us some opening remarks
President Putin please
[Applause]
obey me explain you distinguished mr.
Minister mr. Hannen son madam Solberg
mr. Levin ladies and gentlemen friends I
sincerely welcome all of you to st.
Petersburg the northern capital of
Russia it is a city whose history is
closely interconnected with the
organization of the legendary Arctic
expeditions the industrial exploration
of this unique region the preservation
of its environment and unique culture it
is the fifth time that the international
forum Arctic the territory of dialogue
becomes a platform for a view in
exchange of views a wide exchange of
views on the agenda we are grateful to
our foreign guests to the
representatives of the countries that
are members of the Arctic Council for
their willingness to engage in a
partnership as well as for understanding
that we've got joint responsibility for
the future of Arctic for a sustainable
in stainable stable development in 2021
Russia has gonna assume his chairmanship
in the Arctic Council and will suggest
to all member countries of this
organization as well as other countries
to cooperate in the Arctic the
priorities of our chairmanship all
comprise
burning issues for the development of
the Arctic I refer in particular to the
promotion of environmentally friendly
technologies in no fields and Industry
transport in energy based on the
cutting-edge environmental standards we
implement our projects in the Arctic and
some of them are of global importance if
I said to mention the LNG facility and
the ML Peninsula the exploration of the
Bhavana to scare and corrosive esc'
deposits VRT accounts for more than 10%
of all investment in Russia and I'm
confident that the Arctic factor is only
going to grow in its significance this
year alone we in
tend to elaborate and accept the new
Arctic development strategy for Russia
until 2035 it's gonna comprise both our
national projects state programs
investment strategies of infrastructure
companies as well as the programs for
the development of Arctic regions and
cities in terms of key social and
economic parameters in terms of
standards of living all of the Arctic
regions have to be propelled to a level
no lower than the Russian average I'd
like to draw attention to the fact that
this task should not just be included
and defined clearly in our new strategy
it should be a guideline for all federal
government agencies and regional
authorities of Russia specifics have to
be taken into account related to the
small indigenous peoples of the north a
special attention should be given to
building infrastructure the bulk and
mainstream infrastructure and related as
well and business initiatives have to be
promoted as well among the key
infrastructure projects I can name the
construction of the northern latitude
'''l railway that's a railway that'll
allow us to efficiently start exploring
the mining reaches of polar euro and the
Krasnoyarsk region its northern parts in
future as well as the Arctic as well and
a global transportation corridor is
gonna be built comprising the northern
sea route that is going to work in an
uninterrupted fashion all year through
and my message to the Federal Assembly
in 2018 I said that we wanted to
increase the freight volume there by
2025 to 80 million tonnes yeah 10-15
years ago this figure seemed
unattainable but right now it's a
realistic well calculated girl concrete
girl to accomplish last yeah the freight
volume through
the northern sea route had the mark of
20 million which is three times the
Soviet record which was reached back in
1987 back then the Soviet Union
organized the transportation of 6.5
million tons of freight whereas right
now it's 20 million but for this courage
he hit its maximum capacity we've got to
develop and we're going to develop the
infrastructure both the sea
infrastructure cows to infrastructure
navigation instruments meteorological
satellites as well as other
infrastructure we invite our foreign
partners to help us build hubs in Port I
refer to more months and
petropavlovsk-kamchatsky as the main
terminal hubs we're also going to
modernize the Arctic Coast ports and
organize the capacity for transportation
by River and by sea we're also going to
increase our icebreaker fleet right now
here in st. Petersburg where we are
currently three new icebreakers have
been under construction Arctic Siberia
and URL on the hill by 2035 the
icebreaker fleet is going to have no
less no fewer than 13 heavy icebreakers
and nine of them are going to be
nuclear-powered our goal is to make the
northern sea world
secure safe and profitable to supplies
it's gonna and it should be attractive
in terms of price and the quality of
services the fees have to be well
substantiated for us brake assistance
and that is why the government is
investing into this field in order to
minimize the burden the suppliers the
business incurring friends to increase
the capital investment into the region
we would like to use all the instruments
in particular those that we have already
sexually tested in our development
strategies for the Russian Far East I
refer first and foremost to
preferential income tax rates the
decreasing coefficients for the mining
tax as well as a special procedure for
the v80 reimbursement there is also a
facilitated procedure for getting plots
of land and there's also a clause of
permanence of the conditions for
investment projects they're given the
unique nature of the Arctic the
preferences for the businesses are going
to be even more advanced even more
sustainable the government is working
together with the experts and business
representatives they have been
instructed to come up with a draft
federal law on a special preferential
system for the investors into the Arctic
I would like to request everyone to do
that as soon as possible for this draft
law to be adopted by the State Duma as
early as its autumn session another
issue I'd like to draw attention to
ladies and gentlemen as we know the
powers of the ministry for the
development of the far waist have been
expanded right now the Arctic also falls
within its remedy that is why I believe
it would be a good idea to expand the
institutions for the development of the
Russian Far East to the Arctic as well
but for that we need the additional
capitalisation of the Russian Far East
Development Fund for targeted funding of
projects for a comprehensive development
of this region to address the issues
non-standard issues that we encounter
there so far north we need a new basis
technological basis and in human
resources basis and that is why we have
already got down to build special
training centers integrating research
institutions universities businesses the
real sector of the economy and such a
center is also going to be set up in one
of our Arctic regions it's task is to
develop fundamental sciences and also
Applied Sciences with regard to the
exploration of the Arctic we believe
that the future lies in the hands of
active university exchanges with
the hands of international research
teams and we invite all those who are
interested to work together in
shipbuilding communications safety of
navigation and environmental protection
mining as well as the exploration of
bioresources the Arctic sets before as
enormous challenges we can only live up
to them efficiently if we work together
one of these challenges as I mentioned
before as striking a balance between
economic development and preserving the
Arctic nature saving it's fragile unique
ecosystems as well as eliminating the
damage that as accumulated and the
consumerism consumers to approach to
industrial their activities there we
have been involved in the complete
cleanup of the Arctic starting from 2012
we have taken away there and YouTube and
repressors to more than 80,000 tons of
litter and there are also six
accumulated places of damage in Arcangel
region and Karelian year couch here Anna
Malan and SK district and we are
cleaning up these spots there and the
Kola Peninsula
the colony is also going to be cleaned
up and we're also establishing a new
national parks every first and foremost
to the Russian Arctic National Park it
is important to make sure the additional
measures are taken for environmental
tourism to be full set here and for the
special infrastructure to be set up
there and conclusion I'd like to thank
everyone the guests of all four am I'm
confident that our constructive dialog
is going to help reinforce good
neighborly relations as well as mutual
trust in the Arctic and that in turn
will help us ensure sustainable a
peaceful development of the Arctic thank
you very much for your attention
[Applause]
President Putin thank you very much if I
could just ask a very brief follow-up
question before our next speech you
talked a lot about
Arctic developments and I want to get on
to that later but as we at the beginning
of this panel I'd like to ask you I
guess a broad question about the
politics of the region and indeed the
politics of Russia's relations with the
EU today on the stage we have the
leaders of Sweden and Norway and you
will be meeting them for the first time
in a long time
does this feel somehow like a
breakthrough moment in the sense that
perhaps the bad relations that the EU is
that Russia has had with the EU over the
last few years might be starting to thaw
well unfortunately there is a thaw in
the Arctic that's true and the changes
in the temperature and the Arctic
happening at a faster pace than
elsewhere on the planet and the
temperature changes four times as fast
in the Arctic it increases four times as
fast as elsewhere in the planet but as
far as political relations are concerned
it is a positive shift no doubt well in
my remarks I said that we never severed
our contacts in the Arctic just now I
had a bilateral meeting where the
president of Finland and we recruit that
we had had these meetings on a regular
basis right now Finland has assumed the
chairmanship of the Arctic Council and
Finland has done very much to discuss
and find a solution to the key issues
such as the preservation of the Arctic
nature Finland is paying constant
attention to any issues that might arise
and that we should address together the
Arctic Agenda helps us understand the
need for cooperation for working
together jointly to find solutions to
the challenges we have that is very good
thank you and we'll be talking about the
politics of the region much more later
I'm in the QA but I think now is time
for president
UNESCO of Finland please the stage is
yours